Speaker 1: Let's see what else we have going
on. Let's go to William from Las Vegas. William,
welcome. I was just in Las Vegas not long ago.
Speaker 2: Hello, David. Were you here
again for another convention?
Speaker 1: No, no, no. I just mean,
like, a month ago.
Speaker 2: Oh, yes.
Yeah. So, contrary to your other
callers, you're far better looking
than that guy. So just put that out there.
Speaker 1: Oh, good. Thank you. I appreciate that.
Speaker 2: I have two questions for you.
First, how agile are the Democrats going to be
in the midterm elections, given that we we
repeatedly have these issues where maniacs
shoot people up? We never really solve the issue
because no one's able to find a common ground.
Adding lethal weapons into a school seems like
a bananas idea. That's where they want to go.
I mean, a few years back when a maniac shut up
my town. There's been no progress. So how do
you fight the apathy and the, you know, futility
of trying to to progressively get to a solution?
Speaker 1: It's absolutely infuriating. And
earlier this week, after the Texas mass shooting,
we kind of I went through this cycle where it's
just it's like a rinse, repeat, mass shooting.
Everybody, there's media coverage. Everybody
says we've got to do something. A few days ago,
by then, the predominant voice becomes Republicans
saying, whoa, whoa, whoa, we can't take away any
gun rights. Then a few weeks or a couple of months
go by and everybody kind of stops talking about
it. And then there's another shooting and
it's just rinse, repeat. Here is my hope.
I'm starting to see some polling, some, but not
every poll, but some polling that is showing that
as a result of the forthcoming Supreme Court
decision on Roe v Wade and maybe because of
the obvious non solutions that Republicans
are proposing to the mass shooting issue,
I'm starting to see some polling that's
starting to point in the direction of November,
all of a sudden not looking so bad for Democrats.
Normally it should be a disaster for Democrats.
Joe Biden just won in 2020. You would expect
Democrats to get crushed in the midterm.
Some new polling I'm seeing genuinely seems to
suggest that voters are sick of what's going on
and maybe it actually won't be bad in November
and Democrats might be able to get something
done. It's very, very cautious optimism, but it
does seem like something might be happening here.
Speaker 2: I hope so. It is so frustrating,
especially having seen a maniac shoot up my town
and there'll be nothing done about it. Yeah, I
just have been sick every day. Yeah. So my last
question. If you if you don't mind, sir, I'm
making my first trip to New York City later.
Yeah. And I wondered in Brooklyn area, where is
a good place? A great place, if you're a tourist,
to get a great bagel that represents that city?
Speaker 1: Oh. Oh. Okay, so, listen, if you
are in Brooklyn, my recommendation
is go visit our friends. You know,
I actually don't know because it's been it's
been a couple of months since I've been there
on Smith Street, not too far south of Smith
and Atlantic. Okay. Um, there is a bagel cafe
on the west side of Smith Street. It's
right on the corner. At one point,
it was called mocha bagels. I think now it's
called Smith Street bagels. Maybe go in there.
Tell them David Pakman sent you. They know me
in there. And that is the place I would highly
recommend. They'll make you whatever you want
if you say, Oh, I want, you know, roast beef
on a French toast bagel with maple sirup. I
mean, I wouldn't recommend that, by the way, but
they don't make it for they'll make you whatever
you want. They're the nicest guys in there.
Speaker 2: I think that's close to where I'm
at. I'm in that Boerum Hill Dumbo area where
I'm standing. So I think you're.
Speaker 1: Blocks away from
this. You're blocks away from this.
Speaker 2: Absolutely beautiful. David, thank you
so much for accepting my call. Have a great one.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you.
Wow, what a big day of phone calls here.
It's wild. Let's go next to Brian from
Phenix, Arizona. Brian, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, go near me.
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 2: Awesome. I was just seeing today my
one of my home state representatives, Ruben
Gallego, was sending off some fiery tweets in the
direction of Ted Cruz and some other GOP reps. Do
you think that that kind of engagement online is
effective or would, you know, would actually lead
to change? Or do you think it's more performative?
I'm just wondering what your opinion is about it.
Speaker 1: I think that our lawmakers
don't make policy based on arguments they
get into on Twitter. But I do think that the
performance can have some value because I want to
see elected officials who genuinely seem to care.
And I've interviewed Ruben and he genuinely seems
to care. So to the extent that it's authentic, I
don't I don't care so much about, oh, is he really
going to convince other members of the House
or Senate one way or the other on Twitter? No, I
don't think he is, but he genuinely is passionate,
and I don't mind seeing that on social media.
Speaker 2: Awesome. And then do you expect
related do you expect any federal gun
control legislation to happen after this?
Speaker 1: You know, I, I don't
I really if I'm honest, I don't.
Speaker 2: All right. Thank you. That's it? Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right. No problem. Yeah, I mean,
it's sad, but I just don't. Let's go down to
Texas and speak to Asher from Dallas. Asher, go.
Asha from Dallas. You're on the
air. And last chance for Asher
from Dallas. You are muted. I need you to unmute
or select your correct audio device. I can see
that you're trying to talk, but no audio is coming
through. That could be an audio device issue.
All right. Unfortunately, no actor from Dallas
experiencing an issue, a technical issue. A
technical issue. That's sad to sad to see. Let's
go next to Doug from Alabama. Doug, welcome.
Doug from Alabama. I can see that
you have muted yourself there.
Speaker 2: My bad. Okay. Hey, longtime
listener David, I just wanted to just do,
like, a brief rundown and just get your opinion on
something really fast. Okay. You know, obviously,
we're in Alabama. We got really lucky with Doug
Jones a few years ago because of the whole fiasco.
That's probably the most left person that we've
had ever served because we had Democrats before.
But they were really like Dixiecrats, you know,
they weren't really Democrats. So, you know, it's
it's really sad with the state of the elections
down here. The current, like, democratic,
you know, nominees for governor. I'm
definitely gonna vote for whoever wins.
Um, I really think that, like, Walt Maddox should
have ran again because he was. He was kind of more
of like a Biden kind of centrist Democrat, but
he probably had the best shot down here. He only
lost by, like, ten, ten percentage points last
time. But luckily, it looks like Kay Ivey won. So
she's still really, really bad. But the the
alternative was even worse. But I want to get
your opinion on something. I pretty much know what
your answer was going to be because I've heard
your opinion before. But are you probably going to
be mad at me? But I basically I actually voted in
the primary, but I wasn't you know, I'm definitely
going to vote Democrat in the in November. But I
just chose for some reason, my friend told me
I was an idiot for doing it, but I just decided
to vote in the Republican primary just to get the
the least evil people to win, because I know that
they're basically going to win in November. So
I did. Even though Mo Brooks was like the worst,
probably the worst guy that we could vote for that
his Katie Barrett's even worse and a lot of ways.
And, you know, obviously, Trump doesn't like Mo
Brooks. I kind of just did like a protest vote,
even though I hate Mo Brooks and I don't want him
to win. But I just I don't know. I just wanted
your opinion on that. And, you know, you've
got a show to run. But I appreciate your Doug.
Speaker 1: I love it. I don't know what the
question is, but we love phone calls from Alabama.
And please call in again. Okay. I don't know what
the question is that that was very interesting,
but I'm just not sure what the question is. We're
going to take a very quick break. Just hold on,
because we're going right back
to the phone lines in a moment